there is another side here there's a lot
of regret going on and
cbs news got to give him got to give him
credit where credit's due 60 minutes
ran a special about transgender regret
and the the girls who regret looking
like boys and the boys who regret
looking like girls
in her early twenties grace ledinsky
smith was seriously depressed
and developed gender dysphoria she began
searching for answers in transgender
communities
on the internet and when i saw them
being so happy and excited
about doing this wonderful
transformative process
to really like become their true selves
it was like
have i considered that this could be my
situation too
grace says she found a gender therapist
on the internet
and told her i'm thinking of
transitioning because she was over 18
and didn't need parental consent she
says she merely signed an informed
consent form at a clinic
and got hormone shots just four months
after she started testosterone
she says she was approved for a
mastectomy what's called
top surgery that she told us was
traumatic
i started to have a really disturbing
sense that like
a part of my body was missing almost a
ghost limb
feeling about being like there's
something that should be there and
the feeling really surprised me but it
was really hard to deny
and so she detransitioned by going off
testosterone so you get the idea this
goes on and on i recommend you watch the
whole thing
very pretty girl going through a bad
period where she was depressed
and then some perverts and and psychos
and
and idiots i mean to be to be fair to
them some of these people might just be
stupid but i think a lot of them are
just perverts and they're
they're preying on people's confusion
but some of them might just be totally
ignorant and stupid
they take advantage of this and they say
oh yeah you want to mutilate yourself
you want to lop off perfectly healthy
organs fine by me here you go
and by the way it's not just children
you'll hear that a lot of conservatives
say well you know look whatever adults
want to do that's fine but
just don't do it to the kids well she
was an adult right this this woman was
18 years old
do you think it's right that some
pervert doctor
was was able to facilitate this
depressed
troubled woman's decision to mutilate
her own body
which she almost instantly came to
regret and has now gone back a little
bit
but has suffered irreversible damage do
you think that's good
i don't i think there are
you know as there often are i think
there are probably three positions on
this issue
the left's position is trans everybody
including and especially the kids
right drag queen story hour into schools
let's confuse kids on their sex
let's teach kids in preschool as they're
doing in brooklyn that little boys can
be little girls and let's get everybody
on transgender ideology
then there's the middle squish position
which a lot of self-styled conservatives
hold
which is bad for kids but if adults want
to mutilate their bodies totally fine
and then there's the actual conservative
position which is i don't care if you're
18 i don't care if you're 80.
you should not be able to do this
doctors should not
be mutilating perfectly healthy body
parts and people who are troubled
and want to do this or believe that they
have to do this to be their true selves
are disturbed people and they need
psychological help but they don't need
their bodies mutilated to make their
problems worse
that's those are the those are the three
positions pic pick your choice
they're you know the the the left
authoritarian position
and then the nice wonderful liberal
open-minded position
like women such as this who are 18 years
old should be able to mutilate
themselves even if they're going to
regret it terribly
and then there's the right-wing
authoritarian they're going to call it
authoritarian position
that you shouldn't be able to mutilate
perfectly healthy body parts and take
advantage of disturbed people
where do you fall in that issue i think
you can tell which side i fall on it's
horrible what we've done to these girls
and it's it's obviously this is a the
topic of abigail schreier's book
irreversible damage
which i i think i blurbed that book i
loved it so much in
in the advanced copy and then it became
a big uh big seller so i recommend you
go out and read that one this is not
just one isolated case that cbs news is
covering
this is happening a lot and it's in it
happening increasingly
and for parents who don't know what to
do i understand how confused one would
be
especially if your kid's going to public
school where this insanity is being
foisted on them constantly and you've
got a kid who is very confused about
this
i understand it's a hard decision to
make what do i do what do i you've got a
family member who's going through this
but there's a dark side to this story
that only very rarely comes out into
public light so
well done to cbs for recovering it at
all
these are transparent lies to tell that
pretty girl that pretty
eighteen-year-old girl
you're actually a boy and you need to
mutilate yourself that is a such a
transparent she's not a boy and she's
she wasn't a boy when she underwent the
surgery and she's
still not a boy now that she recognizes
that she's a woman she probably has some
resentment maybe not hopefully you know
but i probably would have some
resentment in a culture
and at these sicko doctors who would
take advantage of me
the lies are so transparent
all right now that i've got your
attention ring the bell ring the bell
subscribe
like make sure that you get the
notifications while you're at it by the
way
head off of youtube and go on over to
our podcast apps you know apple podcast
spotify
google play wherever you listen to your
podcasts make sure you subscribe
we've heard there's some shenanigans
going on with our subscriptions
and our our shows on those apps so just
just to make sure that there's no
glitches or anything like that head on
over subscribe if you wouldn't mind
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you